hello everyone welcome to the gamespot
stage here at e3 2016 I have an
incredible guest with me today well with
myself I'm Justin hey Walt are we not
incredible you are you are in credit or
incredible you're amazing but instead
I've got Jason Vandenberg come on I
can't live up to that you should have
vacation of this place that's not any
way every introduction you do at yuba
sauce press conferences you steal the
show every time so I'm super happy to
have you it was no great to be here and
do you do voiceover work because I do
the most amazing place holder voiceover
you've ever heard I'm amazing place like
this is serious question are you gonna
have some voice acting of yours in the
game but no I always do I always have
because i actually do great placeholder
vo so i always do all the placeholder
and then every now and then they forget
to cut a few of the lines and so i can
sneak into the game so you know massey
don't what lines you haven't for honor
that we might get to hear what kind of a
bunch of stuff in the parts of the
missions that you haven't played right
we've way came with our campaign right
we have these two things and we've got
we've got all these other missions that
we're doing right so those are all the
placeholders are but the real actors who
have done their thing okay so much
you've got like grunts and things in
there we scream some yellow are in the
crowds we're all absolutely the Dominion
deaths and the dark is over yeah we all
get to do those right the crowd one's a
great wheel it's fun packing 20 game
developers into a second booth and
having us all go so foreigner this year
you came off showing your campaign a
story Kambei can you tell me a little
bit how this works cuz there's obviously
the three factions so the three separate
campaigns ditched wine one campaign okay
one campaign were you gonna play as the
Knights and then as the the vikings in
is the samurais and we're going to
divided it into three pieces one big
story right to answer this question
about apollyon and her black stone
legions this says a group of knights
that are that are bringing war more war
to an already war-torn land right
so we're going to get to know what's
going on about these three factions in
their warfare sort of the idea so I mean
how are they all ending up in the same
place because I mean my knowledge of
history is not that good but I do know
that you know ancient samurai Vikings
did not write the the samurai did not
attack the Vikings so we know that
director directly yes there was no great
Viking in you know you know they didn't
happen um so we have a nice rrr trailer
right now the trailer for that and that
establishes this world where where it's
there had been a prior civilization and
then this bad thing happens right the
world gets up Rick you know uprooted and
we all kind of fall back and now we're
coming back out of that right and kind
of refilling these ancients fortresses
and these ancient sanctuaries and all
this this stuff and and but we're now
we're now these old people are bumping
up against each other after a long time
and of course the the resources are
constrained right we're in a better time
now but now we've been warring for so
long and we have so many years and
centuries of ancient warfare to build on
right that that we're over prepared
right and so the wars have just been
kind of a natural stand into that we
bring our villain and the the bplan for
more or I'm gonna get little tin foil
hat here so you mentioned there was a
civilization that came before yes
another famous Ubisoft property has a
civilization I came before are you
saying the foreigner and Assassin's
Creed are in the same universe
absolutely not damn it good yes good
guess but no totally different laces
okay uh in fact like Assassin's Creed is
it's wonderful it's sort of like history
and this is sort of built in our world I
really think of the world of for honor
is kind of like you stepped through the
the sword fighting looking glass right
you're on the other side right where we
can where we can rearrange the pieces on
the board and do all this wonderful
stuff that's what that you know that
long period is all about but it's it's a
new place I think of it as inspired by
our world right like it's you know it's
the it's the way we would want the world
to be if what we wanted to do was fight
with weapons forever so how did you
narrow it down to just these three are
you get because the ones that
immediately come to my pirates ninjas
are these things that are just gone easy
else later or are you like no no that
had to be these three had to wear it
down
well and it's something we sort of
discovered early in the in the
development of the game it was a
question we started asking ourselves its
kind of a classic tree trio in a lot of
ways I found that I could ask anyone you
know to choose like night biking summary
like I can ask you know night by can you
summarize that night night samurai
samurai bank right on it see now here's
the thing you know the answer to that
you knew that answer before I asked you
right you made that decision a long time
ago well why unconsciously yes what's
that about so I want to be at night but
with a samurai sword though well I can't
guarantee of that here uh what we
learned is that i think it's about it's
about what kind of warrior you might
like to be I think it's actually about
values well people who answer nights
tend to have this idea of protection
like defending the weak and sort of the
nobility of the thing they see
themselves in that way right I'm a night
owl indefinitely overinflated ego that's
definitely um I have never played I do
okay well so perfect um people who
choose Viking tend to be reflecting a
choice about passion and living their
life to the fullest an intensity and
beer and parties um and then the samurai
people who choose summer I tend to be
focused on mastery right this is like
the idea of a higher like there's this
higher idea of battle itself and sort of
striving for perfection knowing that you
can't ever achieve it right and so this
idea of becoming that you know so we're
always striving towards those things yes
it sounds like you guys have done some
of you guys had like some psychological
testing going on on the background here
I might be a big geek on that stuff that
might be a part of my whole thing
Rorschach test uh viking helmet this is
a given I give talks at the game
developers conference every year about
player motivation in psycho yeah a big
part of my schtick so uh yes I am into
that for sure hey the helps you know
create the best game for the plate cuz
you're so tailoring it basically to how
people behave how they think yeah if I
know what people find out how people
really think about these things and I I
felt like it we discovered a kind of a
personality test right inside the
Western culture because there's it's
enough right those three the night
Viking summary it's enough right you can
you can you can stop there okay if you
could add more in but most of the other
ones they're all kind of
the same realm right like oh yeah i mean
like ninjas samurai exactly we could
admire it like I go samurai over to the
but yeah you can be right with it with
those values you can kind of cluster
them right because I think those are
maybe maybe those are the three values I
don't know do you play as all three in
the campaign or do you to choose which
one to be okay you play as all three you
play as all three and in orders from
this tale that we're telling you play as
the you start as the night and you play
as a character we call the warden which
is this night who is roaming night
that's coming to the land this is this
area of the world and gets all caught up
in in the this local conflict of the
black stone Legion we call them the
warrior with the warden it's kind of you
right you can pick your gender you can
pick your your customizations kind of
you who you want to be right and then
you play through that campaign and then
we switch to the Raider which is the
character you see here and that's that's
the Raider and again you can pick and
customize I let me do the same thing for
the samurai so you play them all 30 and
all along you're finding out what's kind
of going on right the back Stan would
you think it's more beneficial if you
play the single player before you make a
bold foray into multiplayer it it's
definitely there as a place for you to
play if you don't want to get your ass
handed right it's because we all know
that jumping into a multiplayer
environment is can be humiliating right
yeah no thanks so we'll have a sort of a
brief sort of training bit to get you up
to speed because we have a very new
mechanic but as early as possible we're
going to open up the door let you play
in the multiplayer but if you want to
really study the characters and get good
at that that's what the single players
for the mechanics and the characters
like we're seeing here these are these
are the multiplayer characters they're
the same characters the moves that we
see here in the the powers that you're
seeing here almost all of the abilities
that you have in single-player campaign
transfer directly to the multiplayer so
it's really this one world and it seems
a lot of what you've built around that
is also kind of realistic intruder to to
life is there anything fantastical and
what you've created as well have you
seen how big these guys I have you seen
the other they're huge I'd look small on
camera
sinks into the couch so I love it that
you feel that way I love it seems real
to you but I can assure you people are
like that uh this we think of these we
think of our world is kind of an exalted
exaggerated version of the world we kind
of turned the volume up on a couple of
knobs right realism is where is kind of
part of our imprint ambitions but really
not trying to reproduce melee combat
here right we're trying to reproduce the
emotions of melee combat we're trying to
convince you that you're on a
battlefield right we're trying to
immerse you in that and feel like you
actually have the sword in your hand
right my favorite feedback when is when
when people come back after they play
the game and they're like oh man I feel
like I've been swinging a sword for
hours right like what you mean you're
physically tired they're like it on now
it's just I'm just moving my thumb's
erotic feel like wow I was intense you
know like that that's really what we're
trying to do is get you there um and of
course you've got a brand-new control
scheme how like how did you come up with
that because it's quite I you seem a lot
of iterations uh yes um but it has its
origins it's gonna you it's gonna sound
like a story like I'm making it up but
this actually happened so about 13 years
ago now um I took a course in what's
called German long sword which is the
style of combat that you see with the
warden doing kind of its inspired by
that and I was so impressed with so
struck by how simple the system was and
how clear and sort of learnable and
intuitive that it was as I was like what
would happen if we took this we put it
like on the right stick we took that
system we try to put it there right and
very quickly the basics of the control
scheme that you see with the lock here
and the attacks here right at all that
kind of clicked in place and I got
really excited I was like oh my god this
I think this would work I think you
would feel the way I feel when I do that
see what you would feel like you're on a
battlefield mouths to be amazing so I
started pitching it and for 10 years it
was no no no no right like no thanks
though no good that won't be fine won't
work blah blah and then I pitched at
Ubisoft Montreal for to the GM there and
ironically the answer was no oh the
answer was but it was no but ah nobody
I'd like you to meet this team and I met
I got was introduced to steph card an
and the the was called a fox team at
that time and they're amazing this
team's just incredible and they adopted
me they were looking for a creative
director and they adopted me as their as
a puppy I was like you know yeah I'm
gonna go home we made the game so with
oh sorry we are out of time on getting
the coin where Jason thank you so much
for joining us when can we play for
honor it's februari 14 2017 Valentine's
Valentine's Day green so it's gonna be a
great date game it's perfect thank you
so much for more on for honor and all
the games here at e3 make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot com you're watching
the game spot stage brought to you by
airheads